The Joe Rogan Experience but when you
decided to do this in 2000 when you had
you must have had some sort of uh an
esoteric appreciation yes 100 I just
couldn't describe that to you and I
couldn't map out what year was what wine
I could just tell you that everything
about this wine
is inspirational in some way
uh whether it's like at the age on it
the acid structure something all the all
the Pistons were firing in terms of like
all the sensory
um alarms that are going off in my mouth
the length of the experience like how
it's changing in the glass yeah that was
very inspiring to me as far as actually
being able to map that out for you I'm
an idiot I couldn't do it did you go
through any sort of Education in terms
of like what is involved in the creation
of a wine that you appreciate I just
thought time time and seller like
spending time in in Adelaide Hills at
the at penfolds for a very short amount
of time
seeing it happening around the world
going to wineries while on tour while
they're trying to time it where I can go
when they're going to actually Harvest
today to see what's the equipment are
using what are you doing like how do you
how are you doing this thing like when
did that spark get ignited like what 99
so it was like right before you started
so before that were you a wine
connoisseur were you a wine appreciator
I started appreciating wine maybe around
96. really yeah so just a few years
later you own a Vineyard yeah that's
crazy yeah it just resonated whatever it
was it just clicked right it's like you
know going back to I was talking to
Donald today like he walked into
hixson's place on Pico back in the day
um
Henry Akins walked in the same week that
I walked in to hickson's Academy back in
95. Henry Akins is one of the best black
belts I've ever met I can't I can barely
tie my belt
on you know so it resonated it resonated
with him it made sense to him it clicked
and it went and there's no way you can
figure out what that is to make you know
make him what he is right I was not that
guy I had to work harder at it wine
was like I'd been doing it my whole life
almost instantly it made sense
and then and then slowly backing up and
understanding the chemistry of it
working with people
to go action reaction and logging that
in to develop that you know constantly
but the process
just the basic Logistics of making wine
made sense to me almost instantaneously
and this was from 96 like when no my
first wine that I you know actually was
involved in making who was 2004. oh but
but in 96 when you first started getting
interested in it you went to a Vineyard
you it was just dinners like you're you
know you start to all of a sudden went
from a dude who you know grew up in a
you know lower middle class family with
teachers on you know teach uh parents or
teacher budget you know cutting wood for
the winter
to being on tour with a band and all of
a sudden I can afford
a bottle of wine that was more than
fifty dollars
you know going oh this is cool
seeing all the all the agents and the
the lawyers and the [ __ ] promoter and
the manager and the [ __ ] accountant
all backstage having a nice glass of
wine while I'm drinking Bud Light over
here going with the [ __ ] that I want to
know
grab a glass and try it and went
this is the new thing this is something
I want to know about
and when was the first time you actually
went to a do you remember the first
Vineyard you visited while they were
doing all that
um I want to say it was like 97.
think
98 it was um
Pegasus Bay in New Zealand in New
Zealand
yeah watching the process watching no
that was I think they were doing um
seblanc I think
might have been Pinot I think it was
Pinot but they were de-stemming and I
was watching the stemming process going
okay okay machine
I can afford a machine
and you just thought one day I'm gonna
do that yeah and then the wheels started
getting into motion yep wow
how many people around you are going
Maynard what the [ __ ] are you doing all
of them
[Laughter]
all because it just seems like such a
[ __ ] intensive
complicated
Endeavor yeah
but it's rewarding I mean it's work
you're you're grounding
they're set up there's cleanup there's
Logistics like Tim and I are like the
logistics Nazis like we it's we have to
there's there's a way to do it to not
get in your own way to understand the 16
steps
like today dealing with that triangle I
kept getting my foot caught up and
trying to get the leg around the head
because I was getting in my own way I
didn't I didn't shift enough to make it
so that I wasn't in my own way right in
the cellar I'm not in my own way I'm
thinking five steps ahead and I'm not
going to put a thing down in the way
that I have to move and add six steps to
getting to the next step and this is a
thing that you get better at I get
better at it with every with every
Harvest but I was already naturally
inclined that way as far as Logistics
like Tetris is my thing
hmm
wow that's wild because there's nothing
like that in my mind that that I'm
fascinated by that I would want to go
and start
developing a company that makes these
things
it seems like
it's just so rare that something like
bulb goes off and you're like I need a
wine press
[Laughter]
wow so when you like crack open a bottle
of wine today do you ever open one and
go I should have waited
I mean yeah there's there's those
instances or I open up some of my some
other stuff from before and go yeah I
[ __ ] that up this is a good bottle
it's okay
but I know that I could have done better
on this bottle and what would you have
done to do better well it depends on the
grade depends on what I did and it
depends on the thing but you know
there's adjustments that I've made over
the years that have made it so that
there's a there's a higher percentage of
success
for that for that year what are those
variables it's all depends on the you
know depends on the grape depends how we
picked it depends on what it did too
much Oak is it not enough Oak
you know Oak in the casket yeah well the
cat you know when you're putting stuff
in Barrel is it too new is there too
much flavor I mean imparting too much
flavor on the on the wine I'm not going
back and tasting some of the stuff I
earlier did it's because they were new I
just bought the barrels so there there's
a lot of oak on some of the earlier
wines that I did
um that it's not there now because now
they're older barrels we no longer are
imparting that flavor of Oak so
in hindsight I you know they can't
change it it's done right but I might
have aged the barrels yeah get get more
I get a couple new but buy some neutral
ones from somebody instead so that like
there was just a kiss of oak on it
rather than a lot of new Oak so there's
a company that specializes in creating
barrels no you just go you go to some of
the other wineries that are that are
just cycling through some of their
barrels and you can buy used barrels
from a reputable wineries because I was
going to ask you next do you reuse your
barrels I use as much as much as I
possibly can because I don't necessarily
want the oak influence on the wine but
does the wine that was in the barrel
influence future wines no you're rinsing
it out pretty good you're not you know
you're cleaning them out so what do you
clean it with steam so there's no
chemicals no nothing just water steam
and water yeah wow
how the [ __ ] do you have time for all
this I just don't understand this
logistical time management I understand
but I don't understand where it's coming
from there's no I'm looking at a clock
okay this goes around yeah there's 12 of
those and there's another 12. like where
the [ __ ] is the time